[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAWN ENGLE: My name
is Dawn Gifford Engle.
And my husband
and I 23 years ago
decided to start
something called PeaceJam.
And it's our program which
allows young people to connect
with Nobel Peace Prize
winners, and to learn
how to become
leaders themselves,
and to change the world.
And we have been
going for 21 years.
We have 1.3 million
young people who've
participated in our program.
And we're all over the world.
So it sounds like
a big thing, right?
That's our mission.
But when we started, it was
just a couple of factory worker
kids from Detroit.
Ivan and I are just a
couple of factory worker
kids from Detroit.
And he had a big idea.
And his big idea came out
of a summer of violence
in Denver, Colorado, a
lot of gang violence.
And he is a passionate
Bulgarian, wild man, artist,
the former lead singer of a punk
rock band called The Ramrods--
who are still
infamous in Detroit,
so you can only imagine how
over the top they were--
and writer for "CREEM" magazine.
And he's very artistic.
And he as an artist was living
in the worst part of Denver
and a place where there
was a lot of gang violence
that summer.
The newspapers called it
the "summer of violence."
And 13-year-olds were killing
14-year-olds, drive-by
shootings-- it was bad.
And one day he saw somebody
in his neighborhood--
young kid, 14 years
old-- carrying a gun.
And he called the kid and
his friends over and he said,
what's going on?
You're not in school anymore.
I see you during the day.
What's going on?
And they said, well,
we have a business
and we have a turf to protect.
And he goes, OK,
you have a business,
maybe it's selling drugs.
If you have a business,
you have to be smart
and you need to be in school.
And they said, no, we're out
of school, we don't care.
He was really worried about them
so he kept talking and he said,
who's the President
of the United States?
And they said, I
don't know, and I
don't care because he
doesn't represent us.
They were really disengaged.
But he kept talking to them.
He was so worried, he
kept talking, and talking,
and they stumbled over
the topic of South Africa,
because the miracle in South
Africa had just happened,
this peaceful transfer
of power in South Africa
had just happened.
And these young
people, they knew all
about Desmond Tutu,
Nelson Mandela.
They went off.
They went on and on about
how inspiring they were,
and they stood up to
the man, and they did it
without violence, and they
got their country back.
And Ivan just had this big
light bulb go off over his head
and he said, wow--
if we can put young people
together with Nobel Peace Prize
winners, maybe
that energy that's
going in a negative
direction, it
can go in a positive direction.
Maybe their lives
can be transformed.
Nobel Peace Prize winners
who are walking the talk,
putting their lives on the line
for peace around the world,
these should be the role models
that these young people have.
And so he came and he
started talking to me.
And he started talking
to me because I'm
like the opposite of Ivan.
I'm very linear.
I'm an economist.
I worked for Congress
for 13 years.
I was the youngest
woman ever to be chief
of staff for a US senator.
And when I was in
Washington, D.C.,
I was one of the
very first volunteers
for the International
Campaign for Tibet.
So I knew the Dalai Lama.
So he came and said, we have
to meet with the Dalai Lama,
we have to meet
with the Dalai Lama,
get us a meeting
with the Dalai Lama.
And he kept talking,
and talking, and talking
about this big idea.
And finally I said,
OK, I will do it.
We got the meeting
with the Dalai Lama.
And Ivan said, great,
when is the Dalai
Lama coming to Denver?
And I said, no, no, no, no.
No, we have to go to India.
And he said, I have $1.72
in my checking account--
which was true.
So we had to borrow
money from friends.
And we went and flew to India.
The Dalai Lama loved the idea.
And he said, don't
just work with me,
though, work with these
other Nobel laureates.
He gave us a list
of seven others.
And we went back to
Ivan's artist's loft
in Denver with no heat, asbestos
hanging out of the ceiling,
we've got our coats
on, it's cold.
But we have a big
idea, and a telephone,
and the Dalai Lama said yes.
So we just colcalled the rest of
the Nobel Peace Prize winners,
honest and truly.
Hey, Desmond Tutu, this is Dawn
from Denver, you don't know me
but we have a big idea and
the Dalai Lama said yes.
And we were able to get eight
Nobel Peace Prize winners
to say yes to be our board.
Before we were
incorporated, before we
had any money, before
we had a curriculum,
before we had
anything we were just
two people who were so
on fire with this idea
that we got eight Nobel
Peace Prize winners
to agree to be our board.
And we asked them 10 years
later at our 10th anniversary,
why did you say yes to us?
And they said, well,
it was a good idea
but it was a really hard idea.
No one had ever brought
all the Nobel laureates
together like that before.
And I figured if
anybody could do it,
it was those two
crazy Americans who
had been sitting on
my front porch step
for a week waiting
for a meeting with me.
And it's an example that
we give to young people
because passion matters, ideas
matter, being tenacious really
matters.
And as you see here,
we ended up actually
being married by Desmond Tutu.
We were friends,
we were colleagues,
we started doing PeaceJam,
and we fell in love,
and Desmond Tutu
married us in his church
in Cape Town, South Africa.
And then at the end of the
service, he pulled us aside
and he said, now, people who I
marry, they never get divorced.
So it was like, yes, sir.
So we are stuck with each
other for all of eternity,
but we're really
happy about that.
We're very, very
happily married.
And and we're a great team.
And we've now ourselves
been nominated 17 times
for the Nobel Peace Prize,
so pretty incredible.
And this is what we've
been able to do so far.
It's almost up to 1.3
million young people
who have participated in
our yearlong programming.
What happens is young people
study the life of a Nobel Peace
Prize winner, they
look at what's
going on in their own community,
they create a project that
makes things better
in their own community
or in some other
part of the world,
they get to spend a weekend
working side-by-side
with this Nobel Peace Prize
winner whose life they've
studied and presented
them their project.
Then they go out
and do the project,
they gather again
six months later,
and the cycle goes
on year after year.
So it's education, which is our
curriculum; inspiration, which
is the Nobel Peace
Prize winners;
an action, the most
important part.
It's easy to come
up with a good idea,
it's hard to
implement a good idea.
So we teach those skills so
that young people can become
empowered agents of change.
And we have-- oh,
the slide needs
to be updated-- we're up
to 33 million projects
and we're up to 145
countries for our One Billion
Acts of Peace Campaign.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
So we were doing a
speech in Silicon Valley.
We were at Microsoft
headquarters
and we were doing a speech.
And we got offstage and somebody
from Google came up to us.
And it was Meng--
Chade-Meng Tan.
Has anybody heard of Meng, who
started Search Inside Yourself
and meditation here at Google?
And he bowed to us and he said,
you're doing what I want to do.
I want to create world peace.
And I'm going to kidnap you
and take you to someplace
where they have better food.
And so he did.
He kidnapped us, put us in
his car, drove us to Google.
And we sat there for
three, four hours--
we just kept
talking and talking.
We were so excited
about what could happen
if we started working together.
And so we were able to get--
Google is our lead donor and
tech developer for the Billion
Acts of Peace Campaign.
It's incredible.
We've had over 100 Googlers
working on-- and YouTubers
working on--
this project.
We have half a million dollars
in Google AdWords' budget
every year.
And it's been an
extraordinary partnership.
And we are almost
tripling every year.
We're definitely going
to make the billion goal.
We were just at
Mountain View doing
our annual strategic
planning meeting,
and the campaign is going great.
The campaign itself, the One
Billion Acts of Peace campaign,
has been nominated nine times
for the Nobel Peace Prize.
And we are up for the Nobel
Peace Prize this year.
So cross your fingers, maybe
on October 6 we will win
and even more people
around the world
will be able to join the effort.
But the idea is that, you know
what, our governments are just
polarized, or they're
paralyzed, or they're not
dealing with the really
crucial issues that
are facing humanity, so it's
time for us to act ourselves.
We're not going to
wait any longer.
We're going to get together--
businesses, nonprofits,
universities, cities, towns,
high schools, young people,
old people, everybody,
just a citizens' movement
where we work on what the
Nobel laureates have identified
as the 10 key issues
facing humanity--
things like alleviating
extreme poverty,
access to clean water for
everybody, ending racism
and hate, rights
for women and girls.
So we have a campaign with a
lot of high-integrity moral
leadership.
And this is what we're
focused on doing.
Implementing our
transformational education
program.
We just got a big grant from
the European Commission--
the European Union--
to work with young
people who have just
arrived in Europe who
are refugees-- mainly
Muslim refugees-- and
helping to integrate them,
social inclusion grant working
to build stronger communities
where there is a lot of
divide right now in Europe.
So we're expanding in Europe.
We just started in Singapore,
we just started in Colombia,
we're about to start in Turkey.
So we're expanding
around the world.
And we have our One Billion
Acts of Peace Campaign.
I believe we're going
to reach that goal.
And then I believe that the
Nobel Peace Prize winners--
they're my bosses.
When Ivan and I
started this program--
we're not on the board.
We could be fired tomorrow
without any reason.
It's Colorado, so you can fire
anybody without any reason.
And we are just employees.
We really wanted this program
to be of, by, and for the Nobel
Peace Prize winners.
We wanted it to be their
educational outreach program
to the youth of the world.
And I'm certain that
once we hit a billion
they'll say, great,
now let's go for 10.
And then we have a film series,
the Noble Legacy Film Series,
which is really incredible.
It captures the spirit,
and the essence,
and the cutting-edge work of
all of our Nobel laureates
around the world, people like
the Dalai Lama or Desmond Tutu,
who are getting older.
And we want to capture
them, and their essence,
and their spirit for
all time to share
with people around the
world as a continuing
source of inspiration.
And we've been nominated a lot
of times for the Nobel Peace
Prize.
I was saying to Jeremy it's
a little nerve-wracking right
now, because we're
getting phone calls
at our house from the
Norwegian Nobel Committee.
So I think we're
on the short list--
at least they keep calling.
So we'll see what happens.
But yeah, it's wonderful for
Nobel Peace Prize winners
to believe so strongly
in this movement
and it's wonderful to see
that it's being recognized
internationally as well.
And here's a shot from
our Desmond Tutu film,
beautiful film called
"Children of the Light,"
and the rest of the
films in this series.
So that's all I
really wanted to share
with you is that this
work is going forward.
I don't know if you saw
at the United Nations
yesterday-- a lot of things
happened at the United Nations
yesterday, some good, some bad.
But Governor Brown of
California was there
and he was talking about
something good, which
is that even though our
president has decided
to not implement the
Paris Climate Accords,
cities, and states,
and businesses,
and all sorts of people
are getting together
and we're going to
implement it ourselves.
And so these are the kinds
of citizen, action citizen
mobilization--
working together, we can
actually create the change
that we want to see.
And we're going to go
ahead and start doing it.
We are doing it.
We have 33 billion projects
so far and we're on our way
to a billion.
And hopefully someday our
leaders will follow us.
So that's all I wanted
to say to give you
an overview of PeaceJam.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
JEREMY STANIFER: Thank you
again for being here, Dawn.
Making peace as a job just
sounds like a dream job.
Tell us what about your
job is the best part.
DAWN ENGLE: I'm very hopeful.
I get up every morning and--
OK, I read the paper and then
I try not to get too upset.
Especially since
the election, it's
been every day you read the
paper and it's like, wha?
But I work with
incredible young people,
and they're working
to change the world.
And they're full of hope,
they're full of energy,
they're full of enthusiasm.
So I'm always optimistic.
I see the best of
everybody every day.
JEREMY STANIFER: And laughter.
I'm missing Ivan
right now, because one
of my favorite things
about him is just
being together and
just the light spirit
that you guys bring.
And not only that, but all
the laureates that I've
had the opportunity to meet.
It's a big part of the
culture of PeaceJam.
Can you talk a little bit about
the importance of laughter
and just kindness in the
everyday of what you do?
DAWN ENGLE: Well, I
think one of the things
that Desmond Tutu said that we
hold up as one of our key goals
is never take yourself
too seriously.
And he laughs a lot.
When Desmond Tutu
walks in the room,
it's like a champagne bottle--
just the cork comes out,
and the bubbles
fly out, and it's
like excitement in the air.
He's just funny, and
laughing, and goofing.
And yeah, when he and Ivan
get together it's nonstop.
And we are always doing
things to make it really fun.
When we do a PeaceJam
youth conference,
maybe the theme is
extreme poverty.
It's a hard theme.
But we start by
doing silly games,
and dancing, and just
really silly, goofy things.
And then we do something
really serious.
really, really fun
and we run around the room.
And then we do something
really serious.
Because it should be fun
to be working for change.
It's exciting to be with a lot
of other people who also care.
I think that's the
thing that blows
the minds of most young people.
It's so transformational because
they know that they care,
but they think maybe
they're the only one.
And when they're with 300,
400 young people they've never
met before who are focused
on working for change
but are doing it in
this exuberant way,
it's very, very, very,
very transformational.
JEREMY STANIFER: One
of my favorite moments
seeing Desmond Tutu was
one of the kids asked him
what it takes to be a
Nobel Peace Prize winner.
And he said, you have
to have nice legs.
[LAUGHTER]
DAWN ENGLE: He's very
proud of his legs.
He says you have to have a
name that's easy to remember--
like Tutu--
you have to have a
big nose like mine,
and you have to
have very sexy legs.
So these are our bosses.
So yeah, we're goofing
around all the time.
JEREMY STANIFER: I
think so many of us
want to be involved
in world peace,
in this project especially.
And I think some of the
questions that always come up
is just like where do you start.
I know we have key focus
areas in the project.
Are some examples that you
can have where people can just
do simple acts of peace
today, get them logged,
and get started
with this project?
DAWN ENGLE: That was the whole
genesis behind the platform
that we built together
with the Google team.
The idea is that
people are good,
they want to do something.
They don't know what,
they don't know how.
Or they feel like
they're going to do it
and it's not going to
really make any difference,
it's going to be a
drop in the ocean
and it's not going to make
any difference at all.
So we've created the
platform billionacts.org
where you bring people along.
You start as a tourist, and
then you become a traveler,
and then you become a guide.
We make it easy for you to
do something really simple
and then to look at other things
that are happening in your area
or in the issue area
that you care about.
And you can replicate them
or you could join them.
And then maybe
you get to a place
where you're doing a
project of your own.
But the concept that
it's a continuum,
and that you're not expected
to do anything big, or fancy,
or hard when you start.
It's just getting started.
I'll give you an example.
In Colorado there's
a city called
Arvada that wanted
to do a volunteer
challenge for a month.
And they wanted to
have 15,000 projects.
And they had tried
it the year before
and it was a big failure.
And so they came to
us and worked with us
to use our platform.
And we gave them
a designated page.
And they knew that they could
get the word out to Arvada
that we're all going
to work together
as a community for a month.
They knew they had 35 different
nonprofit organizations
in their community
who needed help.
But they had no bandwidth really
to go out and get volunteers
and to organize around this.
It was too hard.
And they knew that they wanted
to capture what happened
and have data so that they could
show at the end the impact.
But just out of
their own website
they tried the year
before and it was really--
they spent all their
time just trying
to build a website for this
and it didn't work in the end
anyway.
So we were able to provide--
with our platform we
made the magic happen.
We worked with the
nonprofits and they all
signed up all the different
volunteer opportunities
that were available.
We worked with the chamber
of commerce in the city
to get the word out
to all the volunteers
that they had 35
different choices.
There was a way that they could
create their own projects too,
if they had something else
that they wanted to do.
And the goal was 15,000
and they hit almost 30,000.
So having our platform
and connecting
the people who have need--
the nonprofits-- with the
people who have heart--
the volunteers--
and everyone wanting
to work together in a community
and have a combined impact,
that's what we were able to do.
So a lot of tools like that.
That actually turned out
to be the real sweet spot
for the campaign.
When we first started
working with the Google team,
we were thinking we were
going to be building something
that was for individuals.
As it turned out, what
we built is something
that's for power users.
It's for businesses, for
nonprofit organizations,
for universities, for
cities, high schools
and elementary schools
doing school-wide campaigns.
That's who have become our
network members and our power
users, and that's
what's happening
and how we're allowing them
to take an idea or a desire
that they have to
make a difference
and to create change and
have their employees engaged
in something powerful
that's meaningful
that they can measure
the impact of,
and really being able to do it.
JEREMY STANIFER:
One of the things
I love most about
this project is
that it shows just how
much peace there really
is in the world.
You look like what's happening
right now in Mexico City--
we were talking
about this before.
You know just today there
was probably in Mexico City
a billion acts of peace
happening just today.
Especially with 7 billion
people in the world,
there's probably
exponential number
of acts of peace
happening every day.
What's the most difficult part
of getting all of those acts
of peace logged
by the year 2020?
DAWN ENGLE: I'm sure we
won't log all of them.
Our goal is to inspire
many new acts to happen.
So it's not just an aggregation.
But it's also a
different narrative.
If you get up and read
the newspaper every day,
it just feels like
things are horrible,
and the problems
are overwhelming,
and what are we going to
do, and it's hopeless.
And you feel like a victim--
you feel helpless,
hopeless, I give up.
But the reality is that
people are working together
in very effective ways and
really creating positive change
all over the world every day.
And we hold up the Nobel Peace
Prize winners as role models.
We also hold up those who are
doing good work as role models,
and I'll give you one example.
There's a young man in India.
His name is
[? Harish. ?] He's 14.
He read something in the
paper about landmines--
up in Kashmir between India and
Pakistan, a lot of landmines,
a whole lot of landmines
are still there
in the ground, and
soldiers who are
being blown up
when they're trying
to clear those minefields.
14 years old, and
he decides, I'm
going to do
something about this.
And what he decides to do
is he takes some drones--
he had three drones--
and he retrofitted them--
and I'm not an engineer,
but he figured out a way
to make the drones set up
so they could fly
over the landmines,
detect them, and then drop a
little device that blows them
up with only a drone around,
no human beings, no dogs
or anything like
that, so that they
could clear landmine fields.
And so it's a wonderful project.
He's a very smart young man.
He deserves to be known about.
So his project was
logged on our site.
We picked him as the winner
of one of our hero awards.
And every year in Monte
Carlo we have a big event.
We have a premiere
of one of our films.
We have a PeaceJam
youth conference.
And we give awards
to the projects
in the world that are the best.
And we always say that we treat
peacemakers like celebrities.
And it really is
fantastic to be there
and to see them get a
international spotlight.
He got a TED talk.
His project's been bought
by the Indian government.
He's on his way.
So being able to
hold up people who
are doing inspirational,
incredible stuff
around the world--
and he's just 14 years old.
You may say, oh, he's
so much smarter than me.
But then we have
other people who were
doing other things as well.
So you don't have to
have a Ph.D. to start.
You don't have to be brilliant
to make a difference.
You just have to have heart and
soul, and reach out your hand,
and help at least
one other person.
All of us can do
that, regardless
of our circumstances.
And if we all did that, the
world would be transformed.
JEREMY STANIFER: I agree
that's super powerful.
I think that the story
about [INAUDIBLE]----
it's interesting because this
week at the United Nations,
at the Social Innovation Summit,
one of the things that was most
talked about was using the
power of technology for not only
to innovate but for human
progress versus just solely
financial reasons.
There's an urgency
with all of that,
now especially with the
climate that is changing,
especially all the hurricanes
and things that are happening
with the environment.
Can you talk a little bit about
the urgency in today's climate
about a project like this?
DAWN ENGLE: Well, absolutely.
I was reading something in
the "New York Times" yesterday
about climate change--
we'll break it down for you.
How bad is it?
It's real bad.
What can we do?
Ooh, we'd better hurry.
So if you want a good, really
very simple but clear breakdown
of where we are, the world
has warmed two degrees.
If it gets up to
eight degrees, we
won't be able to support
this amount of people
alive on planet Earth.
So what does that mean?
We are already seeing
environmental refugees, people
who where they live it's
flooded, it's a drought,
it can't sustain life.
Wars will be fought.
Many people will die
from the extreme weather.
We're seeing the
extreme weather.
We're seeing the rising seas.
It's already happening.
We can't stop it from happening.
But we can lessen the degree to
which it happens if we act now.
But we really have
to take it seriously.
And again, it's hard when
our leaders don't lead.
But we can lead ourselves.
And that's our point,
is coming together.
And then you don't feel
like you're all alone.
Like, OK, I'm recycling,
I turned off the lights
when I left the room, it's not
going to make any difference,
the world's going to hell.
That's the feeling that
a lot of people have.
And to have people be inspired,
and part of a movement,
and to be in
community with others
who are doing the same
work, you don't feel lonely.
You feel empowered, you feel
excited, you feel enthusiastic,
you know you're reaching goals.
And that's what this
campaign is all about.
It's about unleashing goodness.
We really, really believe that
every single human being who's
born on planet Earth
has goodness in them
and greatness in them and
we're unleashing that.
And if we see ourselves
in a different way,
we can be empowered
and we can be
extraordinary agents of change.
JEREMY STANIFER: How do you
see technology's biggest role
in all of that, considering
what we just talked about
with the Social
Innovation Summit?
DAWN ENGLE: Well
again, the examples
that I give from
our campaign-- there
are people who want to do good.
They don't know how.
They want to be part of a
community, it doesn't exist.
They want to create a campaign,
or a movement, or a project;
they need support.
So it's providing
the underpinnings
to make all of
those things doable
as opposed to sitting there by
yourself feeling like, ah, it's
too hard.
So it's allowing
people to get started,
at least with the
technology that we've
developed working with Google.
But I think in the
broader sense--
we're talking about the
example of the drones
and the landmines--
technology can be used
for tremendous good,
it can be used for
tremendous evil.
So it depends on the
ethics of the people who
are creating the technology.
So I think that's also
very important too.
So that's one of the
reasons that we really
care deeply about sharing
these Nobel Peace Prize
winners as moral
examples for the world,
having an alternative narrative
to the things that we're
hearing so constantly
that are so negative.
The most recent
film that we did is
called "Without a Shot Fired."
It's about Costa Rica and
how they made the decision
70 years ago to not
have an army and instead
to invest their money in
health care, the environment,
education, and housing, and the
impact that had on Costa Rica
and the rest of the world.
And it's a choice.
So we don't have
to say that we're
going to solve our problems
with military force
or by having a doubling
of the size of our army.
A lot of the things
that you're hearing now,
there are alternative
ways to go about it.
And different countries
and different leaders
have tried different approaches,
and they have worked.
And so having
other voices heard.
So we want to amplify the
voices of our Nobel Peace Prize
winners, and of all of the young
people, and all of the others
around the world
who are doing things
in a positive, nonviolent way.
But we really, really believe
in the path of nonviolence.
There was a study
that was just released
that shows about
working for change
and if you use techniques of
violence versus techniques
of nonviolence.
And nonviolence is the
change that will last.
It has the best
chance of succeeding
and it has the best chance of
actually lasting and making
a difference for social
justice in that situation.
So these are the
stories that we're
trying to share with the world.
JEREMY STANIFER:
One last question
and then I'll open it
up to the audience.
Why youth?
DAWN ENGLE: I love working
with young people because--
JEREMY STANIFER:
You and me both.
DAWN ENGLE: It doesn't matter.
PeaceJam started because of
some young people in a gang
and Ivan got into a
conversation with them.
And even the toughest kids,
they're like puppy dogs.
They have their heart and
their soul is right here.
And maybe it's buried
under a few layers
of trying to be tough,
but they want to be loved,
they want to belong,
they want to matter,
they want somebody
to see the goodness
and the beauty in their soul.
That's what they want.
And if you do that,
they bloom like flowers
turning towards the sun.
It's incredible to
see that change that
happens with young people.
Our program starts at age
6 and goes through age 25.
In the elementary schools,
a lot of young people
don't know that there
is this thing called
the path of nonviolence.
There's the words
that adults say
and then there's what adults do.
So in the movies, what do we
do when somebody does something
that we don't like?
We go and bomb the
hell out of them.
What does our government do?
We're going to wipe
North Korea off the map.
Young people are smart, and
they're paying attention,
and they're seeing
all of these things.
Maybe the adults are saying
nice words, like "be kind,"
but they're not being kind.
And so they look at all
of these role models that
are being presented in
media, in video games,
in leadership around the world.
And when they start studying
the PeaceJam curriculum,
they're like, ah,
there's something
called the path of nonviolence.
It's a huge discovery for them.
And we didn't expect
this, but in schools
where our curriculum is being
taught, one of the big impacts
is on behavior, because
young people now
have nonviolent role models.
The teachers say that
they're in the playground
and they're like, well,
Rigoberta Menchu wouldn't
do that, or, what would
the Dalai Lama do?
So giving them
positive role models
who are solving
really hard problems
but do using the path of
nonviolence to solve them.
In elementary schools there's
something called an incident
report when there's a fight.
And in some schools,
especially with schools
that have a lot of turnover,
transient populations,
poorer schools-- a
lot of our schools
have a lot of youth
who are homeless
or who with the job
insecurity for their parents
there's a lot of moving.
And so in those schools,
it can be for teachers
that they spend all of
their time just trying
to get everyone to sit down,
be quiet, stop fighting, pay
attention, and very little
time to actually teach.
So in schools where the PeaceJam
program has been implemented,
the incident reports of
fights has gone way down.
And the teachers have
been really thrilled,
because they get to
spend their time teaching
and the young
people are engaged.
JEREMY STANIFER:
Almost here too they're
inspired too not only by these
Nobel Peace Prize winners,
but Nobel Peace
Prize winners are
going against the status
quo, which is probably also
inspiring to someone
who is a teenager
and seeing things that might
not make sense to them.
If you do reach those
billion acts of peace,
you said the next step would
be 10 billion acts of peace.
It's this exponential curve.
You see and you hear all
this white nationalism,
all these weird things that
are happening in our country,
and that can sometimes
be the story for us.
But it's sometimes
this exponential curve
that you're seeing that
actually the goodness is
starting to come out.
Do you think that once you hit
the one billion acts of peace,
do you think 10 billion acts
of peace will be a lot easier?
DAWN ENGLE: Anything
can become normal.
And I think that's
what we have to be
really careful about right now.
The kinds of things that white
nationalists, and racists,
and hate speech--
there are things that were
maybe underground that
have been legitimized
in a way, they
feel like they've been
legitimized by our leadership
in this country right now.
And a lot of stuff's come out
that is pretty concerning,
like it's OK to do certain
things in certain ways.
And peace can become normal too.
Kindness can become normal.
Compassion can become normal.
Anything can become normal.
So it's what we focus on
and what we model ourselves.
So that's the idea.
Really the core idea behind the
Billion Acts of Peace campaign
is that we have
to work at scale.
If we have 7 billion
people on planet Earth
and we have a
billion acts of peace
and then 10 billion
acts of peace,
it's enough so that it can shift
the consciousness worldwide,
and that we can see that
there is another way,
and that it is a
very successful way,
and that there's enough of
it happening in communities
around the world.
We're in 145 countries
around the world so far.
And just making it
normal to reach out
your hand, to help someone
else, to be compassionate,
to care, to act.
Emotion without
action is irrelevant.
You feel really bad when you see
those stories about the people
in--
the Rohingya being expelled from
Myanmar, but they need help.
They need compassion.
It's good that you
care, but they need
people to actually help them.
And some of it's social justice,
some of it's humanitarian aid,
some of it's legal rights.
So we can create
a different world.
It's just that we
give up our power.
So that's the last
thing I'll say.
I'll end with that, is that
we have the power in our hands
to create whatever kind of
world we want to create.
We give our power away.
And we vote once
every two years,
once out of every four
years, and then we're done.
And we just, oh, well,
that's the way it is
and there's nothing I can do.
And we need to take our power
back, as human beings who care,
and work together to
create the world that we
know that we want to see.
We know we can do
better than this.
Come on, we can do
And so we're not going
to wait any longer.
We're not waiting, we're
creating that new world
together.
So we're just really,
really grateful to you
for being a member of our
team and such a good friend
and to everybody at
Google and YouTube
who has been so
incredible supporting us.
We have three wonderful
executive sponsors--
Bradley Horowitz, and Karen
May, and Susan Wojcicki.
And it's just been a
beautiful partnership,
and I know it's going
to continue to grow.
So we're very, very happy to
be in partnership with you all.
And thank you to everybody
who came to this talk today.
Thanks so much.
JEREMY STANIFER:
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]